hey y'all insander couch here and this
tight tuesday video
we're not going to be looking at this
week's data set instead we're going to
continue to work on the title
tidy models packages and focus on
classification models specifically on
the model metrics
so when we think of uh classification
model metrics
we always think of like accuracy but
the accuracy is basically pose of the
confusion matrix
which the confusing matrix has four main
values
true positives false positives also
negatives
and true negatives you may also have
heard of like sensitivity
specificity the true positive rate
false positive rate precision recall
all of these values or all these metrics
are basically composed
off of the confusion matrix so that's
what we're
focusing on and what we're uh what's
cool about the tidy models package
uh is that there's a package called the
yardstick package
and this will basically be the main
package for
um basically calculating and
calculating and charting out these uh
metrics
so let's open up a our markdown file uh
our markdown
i'll call is tidy tuesday
classification metrics
okay
and delete this garbage uh i'm going to
open up the
tidy verse uh
was it tidy models and we're actually
going to be using the same data set
from last week's video which is the
customer
churn data set
um i would also like to say that um
you should subscribe to my channel
because every week
i make a video trying to teach about uh
data science
and i've definitely focused a lot on my
videos on
predictive modeling using tidy models so
if you want to get better at tidy models
or just learn about machine learning
uh hit the subscribe button and i'll see
you guys next week
so you guys heard my elevator pitch and
let's actually start
analyzing this data set and creating
some models so when we're looking at
this data set
the first thing that we should really be
doing is counting the class
that we're trying to predict in this
case this is a customer return data set
so we're trying to predict
whether a customer will stop our service
or not in this case
since we counted the things that we're
trying to predict we can see that
there is a difference in the nodes and
the yeses
where there are much more p customers
who will stick with our service
and customers who will stop our service
additionally we would want to consider
the yes
as the positive class so we can see that
there's a
cost and balance in the positive class
so we can say this
evaluate uh class imbalance
we can see that the yes um is imbalance
and that'll actually
affect of how we evaluate our model
so if we also look at our levels so if
we do churn
and then levels
oops oh god you can't pipe that
if we look at our levels
uh whoa what df
uh level
oh i know why uh as dot factor
so if we convert these things to a
factor we can see that
um the factored levels are in a
different order
uh with the tidy models uh they actually
view the
the positive class as the first factor
first level in a factor so we're gonna
have to keep that in mind so if we say
this we'll say
need to change
levels or churn
okay so now let's actually clean the
data
um we do a summary
we can see that most of them are
characters
we're also missing some nas so what i'm
going to do first
is i'm going to drop the nas
and i'm going to convert all of them to
a factor
so all these features will be factors so
as
dot factor
and now i'm going to actually fine tune
and convert the
few features into a numeric feature so
in this case we're going to say
tenure is a numerical feature
monthly charges
is a numerical feature or continuous
future
and let's see your total charges is our
numerical feature so as dot
numeric total charges cool
so we did that and that will be our data
cleaning
uh it's pretty fast and we're also not
going to do any crazy feature
engineering either because i want to
focus this video
mostly on the metrics and not the actual
modeling process
oops uh if we also look at our uh oh
so now we should also uh create change
the levels so if we see
the levels df
churn we still have it no yes what we
can do is actually re-level the data so
a change levels if we do df
mutate churn is equal to vector
reverse churn
and then we do levels df turn
we can see that we just swapped the
order so that way we can uh have the yes
as a positive class
great so now let's actually create uh
our train
test and validation sets
uh i'm gonna set the seed for
reproductive
so you can replicate it i can never say
that word uh it's a tongue twister
uh so now i'm gonna create the was it
the uh
what the data splits so data split
initial split idf
prop equals point a we'll say strata is
equal to churn so that we have
equal classes for um each split
oops uh and then we'll say uh train
data training
test data testing data
split and then i'll say uh k
folds iv fold
cv give it our train data
and then we'll call that day so we
created that
this will act as our validation set for
our tuning of the model
okay so now we're going to actually do
the pre-processing
we're just going to do a basic recipe so
we'll say recipe
turn data equals train oops data
equals train data step
remove because we want to remove the
actual uh customer id
so we'll just remove that
we'll uh basically normalize
all of the nominal variables or all the
all the
numeric variables um i just did a step
range because then i'll
we'll know that it just converts it to
uh in a range of zero and one
you can obviously do step normalize or
step normalize
and box [ __ ] you can also do step
center step scale
but i figured step range was just kind
of like a thing to do
um definitely up to you know the
modeler's discretion
we're also going to do step dummy and
say all nominal
but we don't want to do the um
the outcome which is our turn
um i'm also going to say one hot
is equal to true because i don't want to
have
any degrees of freedom i kind of just
want to have the um each feature being
representative
okay so i'll say model rec
if we do model rack prep and then
juice we can see it actually being
applied to the training set
and we can see that we have our
hot encoded variables um if we do the
summary
we can see that if we look at the min
and max's that
all of them are between zero and one
so it's doing exactly what we want it to
do
okay so now we're actually looking at
the metrics
so what we're going to do is we're going
to say like classification
class we'll just call them c metrics
and what we can do is when you're doing
a classification model in tidy models
they'll always give you the accuracy but
in this case what we're going to do
is we're going to just give it a whole
set of metrics
first we're just going to give it
accuracy um
we also want sense and sensitivity and
specificity
i'm also going to include aoc and roc
and then i'm also going to use the m
mean log loss
so let's go back to this and we'll see
accuracy
accuracy is just the total true
positives plus the total true negatives
divide by a total amount of observations
okay sensitivity is this the was it the
true positive
rate uh divided by
the true positive plus false negatives
so out of all the
um out of all the positive classes
how many were correctly predicted and
then
uh was it and then specificity is just
out of all the negative classes
how many of the negative classes were
correctly predicted
okay which is pretty useful just on like
an information standpoint
so um if you're saying like okay we want
to figure out how many sick people
um out of the population how many sick
people
were correctly identified it's pretty
useful
but there's also other metrics
specifically that uh
the true positive rate and the false
positive rate
so a lot of these metrics are kind of
like
uh they measure slightly different
things but they're definitely linked to
each other
um which can cause some confusion
but we're not gonna have to worry about
that yet uh we'll get into that after we
start making our models
i'm also doing a model control where
i'll do model uh
we'll do a control grid and i'll just
save the predictions
so that way we can add any other metric
we want
using the yardstick package so for the
actual modeling
um i'm going to start cr i'm just going
to create one model
and this model will be a k n model i'll
say nearest
neighbor neighbors equals
tune set mode
classification set engine
kknn
and i'll say knn grid so i'm going to
create a grid
of neighbors i want to tune so grid
regular
parameters canon model
and i'll say levels or the amount of
parameters i want to tune five
so if we look at our canon grid we can
see we have five
uh sets of five different uh neighbors
that we can
five to five values of neighbors that we
can uh
check and then i'm gonna do a tune so
i'm gonna
do a tune grid give it a model
give it a model recipe
uh give it some resamples so we can have
some robust estimation of our actual
metrics in this case it'll be our was it
our k
bolts give it our control which will be
equal to our model can
control and then we'll also give it our
metrics which will be uh was it
uh was it what did i call it again c
metrics
cool and we're going to tune that model
so let's go back to our actual uh i'm
gonna put this to our
uh to my other monitor just so i can
make sure that
it runs so we can also look at this
so what is uh sensitivity
is the true positive over the total so
we look at true positive
divided by true positive false negatives
oops
we have the uh specificity true
negatives
divided by true negatives plus the false
positives dope right there
so it's this this column um
there's also a positive predictive value
which is definitely
very um uh close to
the sensitivity rate which is the true
positive divided by the false positive
and how this differs from the positive
how the pros
positive predictive value or precision
uh
basically is different from sensitivity
is precision
measures basically how how certain we
can be that our model is correct
whereas sensitivity basically measures
how much of the the sample we got
correct
so you know one goes from the model's
perspective and what goes on the data's
perspective
but we can look at it in our yardstick
uh using the yardstick package
so let's do can tune collect
metrics right now we have basically
all of our metrics that we uh that we
specified
if we do what is it uh a gigipot
x equals what was it neighbors
y equals mean
uh point plus gm line plus
facet crap
metric scale sequence
igm
so what we can see here is if we look at
it
overall when we increase if we just look
at our accuracy
when we increase our neighbors our
actually is increasing
additionally our loss is decreasing when
we increase our neighbors
our roc aoc score is increasing
and also our sensitivity and specificity
are increasing
however with sensitivity it has a slight
uh
downward trajectory or slight little um
bottoming um what we can also
look at is basically our
um in sample so every every sample's
um a metric so if this is basically the
average
we can just look at like the actual uh
frequency of it
so what we can do is we can say uh
select id
and dot metrics on s
dot metrics and now what we can start
doing is just like
uh plotting that out so ggplot a
um actually i'll just yeah a yes
x equals neighbors y equals dot
estimate um
point plus gm
[Music]
line plus facet crap dot
metric scales is equal to a free
y right so now we have a little bit more
variance in it
in fact if we actually do our was it
our color is equal to id
we can see all our folds so i'm going to
do theme
legend.position equals none
so this kind of shows us why it's good
to have
every fold i'm going to do cables cross
validations so we can see kind of like
the variance between each fold
or between each partition data set you
see there's still some stability
with like say meanwhile gloss rcaoc um
and even a little bit of accuracy but we
see our sensitivity is all over the
place
so this is kind of a good for just
evaluating you know your primer tuning
but
one of the things that we should be
looking at right it's just the confusion
matrix of it
so how we can do that is if we do our k
and
k nearest neighbor tune uh we can just
do collect
we say collect predictions
this will give us every folds
predictions with also
the cost probabilities
so i kind of went over sensitivity and
specificity but let's kind of go
let's just show the actual um
confusion matrix so i can do is mutate
pred equals if else dot pred
or prediction is above equal to 50
or above we'll just say it's a yes else
it's a no
and then i'll say mutate uh predator
equals as that factor
uh pred right and what we can now do is
just use the conf
mate which is confusion matrix and we
just give it our turn and our pred
levels are not in the same so what i can
also say is
red equals uh f
fsct or was it reverse
pred so now we have a confusion matrix
right um i'm actually going to do this
and say
conf i'll say uh conf
i'll say was it c data
data metric
uh oops i'll just see data metric and
then we say
c data metrics off matte
turn red
oops so we can see our true positives
and our our true negatives our false
plazas and our false negatives
and really um i would say you shouldn't
be too bogged down on the
you know what what is sensitivity
specificity
uh you know what's precision recall uh
what's
what's the false discovery rate they're
all just confusion matrix metrics so one
of the best things i would recommend is
just
looking at the confusion matrix and
figuring out whether it's a good model
or not
in this case if we just looked
at our accuracy right so c data metric
and we can say was it accuracy
give it our turn and give it our pred
we can see that wow we have a 74
accurate model
doing basically no tuning no future
engineering i just threw it at it
and it's pretty good ten four percent
you know you could probably squeeze
another ten percent and have
have a pretty great model but if we
looked at our confusion matrix
we can see that we're not really
predicting
uh whether someone will churn or not in
fact when we make a prediction
we're only right a little bit more than
50 of the time right
so when we predict yes uh half 75
uh 7 500 times it was true and then 7
000 times it was not actually
a churned customer which is why
if we actually do our sensitivity we can
see our sensitivity score
is is relatively low it's 0.5 we want we
really want to maximize our sensitivity
score
right because our sensitivity score is
taking
our our truths which is 75 20
720 divided by
75 20 plus 74 or 40.
oops 7520
plus 7440
right so out of the total uh positive
classes
how many do we actually uh correctly
guess
we can also measure how confident our
how we can also
uh kind of measure how confident our
model is so the positive predictive
value
um and that's just that's just uh doing
this so c
data metric i'll make this a little bit
better and
what we can do is
so if we give it our churn and then we
give it our
thread we can see our pause project
value is 51
which makes sense because 75 20 divided
by uh 7520 plus 747
it should be a little bit higher than 50
okay so that's how
our predictive value so we can say
calculate
our predictive uh our ppv
so these are all metrics of basically
like how certain our model can be
given an unbalanced data set um or given
like
a a specific um uh class that we want to
specify them
what we can also do is the roc aoc
so what's good about this uh rcaoc
is it basically measures uh
two um randomly guessing
so if we look at our can re
uh was it canon tune
collect metrics
and then we could say um was it
filter.metric is equal to roc aoc
and then we can say top n mean n equals
1.
we can see that our best model
has 14 neighbors with an roc aoc score
of 0.79
uh one way to visualize an roc aoc score
is to show the roc curve because
basically basically when we're trying to
evaluate
a imbalanced data set the aoc score
is the best way to measure it because it
kind of encapsulates um
and kind of adjusts for uh
the imbalance data and balance class
so if we look at our was it our k n tune
uh collect predictions
and then let's say we do a uh group
by id
group by id and then what we can do is
roc curve give it our turn
which is our our true value and just
give it our probability of yes
so now we have that and then we get what
we can do is use
uh auto plot it'll auto plot the roc aoc
scores
so the roc aoc score is basically the
comparison between
the sensitivity and one minus
specificity
and the big idea between the roc curve
is that we want
our curve basically touching the left
corner
and aoc is just the area under the curve
so the
basically the more the curve is to the
left top left
the higher the aoc score which is why um
you need to use the aoc score instead of
roc curve the roc curve is just
a curve right it's just a line there's
no like um
kind of a there's not really a
measurement of a line that's why the aoc
is basically this
uh summarization of the of of this curve
so that's why we use roc there's also
other metrics
that um can kind of substitute to the um
roc aoc curve
such as the balanced uh balanced
accuracy
if we do balance accuracy um it base
computes the average of the sensitivity
specificity which is kind of like this
overdose sensitivity and one
myospecificity
you can also do uh gain curves
which is turn up which is the same
procedure as a uh
roc curve but what this is measuring is
basically
um like how much of the class you can
capture
uh given the cost probabilities so
basically it's saying if we
say that everyone with the 50
probability of being a yes class or less
is a yes then we can capture about
75 of the of of the actual
um of the actual uh
points then as we keep on increasing
i mean i'm talking i'm sorry the bottom
50 like
so it's saying like from 99 to 0.55
to 0.5 we can capture about 75
of our turned customers if we keep on
increasing this threshold so right here
to basically 0.25 to 100 confident
we can capture about uh eighty percent
and you can see that there's some
diminishing returns because generally
if if we're saying that um this we're
ten percent sure our model ten percent
sure that this customer will
uh will uh
will turn uh generally they won't
however there will be some that slip
through the cracks
so you can see this kind of diminishing
return and this is really good for
business use cases
so for example if we are trying to
basically spend some money
to prevent these customers to churn so
if we have a bottle that says these guys
will churn
in the next month we should send out a
coupon
or a voucher you know worth about like
say say 10 bucks right we have some
analysts to run that
we can't give a 10 coupon to all of our
customers
because then we'll lose a lot of money
so one way to do it is
we'll just give it to the customers who
are 90
who our model is 99 90 confident or more
that they'll churn because we think that
since
they're highly likely to turn we'll give
them the coupon first right
uh so basically we're based trying to
find
out using a gain curve
what are the what are the most
vulnerable
causes or what costs are we most sure of
that we should start uh looking at
and how how many of them can we actually
capture
so gain curves and lift curves which is
kind of other counterpart are huge in
the business
world and it's something you'll actually
probably see
so this is mostly um all of the metrics
that i would say
that you should kind of understand
always uh be aware about
but what's cool about yarsik is that
there are a lot of metrics
so for example uh there's also mcc
matthew's correlation coefficient the j
index
f measures uh detection prevalence
uh there's the area under the precision
recall curve
roc curve using a uniform class
distribution so there's a lot of things
i haven't gone over meanwhile across um
but there's a lot of metrics and i think
i'll probably make another video on
regression metrics too
but i want to show you one other thing
uh one other
metric that i i try to do for all my
models after i train it
so um and this is kind of a good post
hoc metric to look at
so if we do can tune select
best and then our metric is equal to
roc aoc we see our neighbors is 14.
okay so in this case what we're going to
do is we're going to create our final
model we'll say we'll just kind of give
it our
uh what is it we'll do our finalize
model uh was it mars
what is uh what would it call it again k
n
k n model and then can
tune uh select best uh
canon
ooh what what parameters
oh well i'll just i'll just do this
sorry i'm not gonna look up how i do it
again
um so canon so neighbors of 14
has the best uh roc aoc curve
uh roc aoc score so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to go to our
model i'm going to select this
so 14 so neighbors is equal to 14.
i'll say last fit k n
model and then was it uh was it data
split
uh what is it you must process
oh oh yeah yeah sorry sorry geez uh uh
now i'm gonna create a workforce so
final model uh
workflow add model
canon model add a recipe
uh was it a model
rack
and then final res give it our final
model
and our data split
so we did that so let's say
collect metrics and fit to model
so we have our final res uh what i'm
gonna do is
collect the uh collect predictions
okay and
what i'm gonna do is basically uh mutate
i'm going to say i'm going to select the
prediction so pred
class oops dot pred
yes and then churn so this is what we
predicted
and this is the the actual results what
i'm also going to do is basically do
some mutations so i'll say
dot prod equals 100 times dot pred
yes right and i'll say select
minus dot pred yes
and then what i'm going to do is mutate
and i'll say dot pred is equal to
round dot pred uh devi five
times five so i'm basically um kind of
rounding it to the nearest five
and then finally what i'm going to do is
count dot pred and
churn then
i'm going to say pivot wider names from
is equal to
ch turn values
from is equal to n
okay and then finally i'm going to say
mutate prob is equal to
yes divide by yes plus
no
and then finally i'm going to mutate
prob is equal to 100 times prob
so what am i doing what i'm basically
trying to measure is
so when we give it a probability of
being yes
what is the actual probability of we
observing these outcomes
so when we see a probability if we say
that this person will turn
50 of time we want to see that these 50
labeled uh these costs that we say are
50
of time will be yes to actually end up
being
resulting fifty percent of time so if we
do that so ax equals dot
uh pred y equals prob plus gm
point plus geom smooth
um and then what i'm going to do is geom
kb line plus chord fixed
excel m equals equal to c 0 100
yl m is equal to c 0
and what what is this is basically kind
of like a cal well i think it's called
like a calibration group
it's basically saying that if we say so
these are the points where we said
yeah this will be this this these
customers will turn 50
of time 50 of those customers actually
turned
okay we can say oh hey here's we're
saying that you know when we give it
like say one percent of time
these customers probably actually turned
ended up two percent of time
so this is kind of a good curve a good
little way to basically
um evaluate how accurate is of class
probabilities
when uh predicting values and
uh is good for business use cases so you
can kind of actually reasonably assign
these probabilities as true
probabilities instead of model
confidence
so um we i know we went kind of fast i
was just going over the main metrics
of of the
my confusion matrix using classification
models but i think this is basically the
main things you really
need to go over and really need to know
um
i would say don't really worry about all
the jargon of sensitivity
specificity true positive rate false
discovery rate
it's a positive perfect value all that
is a function of the four main metrics
of the confusion matrix and always look
at the confusing matrix confusion matrix
think about uh what you really want to
optimize
and then start doing the modeling so
i'll see you guys next week and tidy on